I do nails and I just opened up a silver
shop and I don't know how to balance my
time between them my beautiful family
and doing what I love love in itself is
a balancer even just being around the
four of you right now I have a very good
feeling that they're not confused that
you're not about them they know that you
love them because there's a lot of
people that are home at five o'clock
every night they're they're plenty and
the kids and the husband and the wife
like don't feel the love balance is
individual balance is very
circumstantial what I think about is
balance of heart and intent and love I
have a funny feeling that if one of
these three needed you that the silver
shop in the nail shop you'd burn to the
[__] ground yes it was well that's
the [__] answer to your question and
by the way you're also inspiring them
you're showing your daughter what it's
like to be a [__] boss female to
execute you're showing her that example
balance is based on the intent not the
[__] logging the hours so you're home
but you're all watching TV and not
talking to each other what the [__] did
that mean yeah you understand I I get a
thousand percent